من أجل جعل أمريكا عظيمة
ومجيدة مرة أخرى ، أعلن الليلة عن
ترشيحي لمنصب رئيس الولايات
المتحدة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السيدات والسادة الأجانب
الضيوف الكرام
وزملائي المواطنين تبدأ عودة أمريكا
الآن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى  ]
أصدقاء
أجانب
ولكننا الآن أمة في حالة تدهور ،
نحن أمة فاشلة بالنسبة لملايين
الأمريكيين لقد كان العامان الماضيان تحت حكم جو
بايدن وقتًا من الألم
والقلق واليأس
حيث نتحدث عن التضخم هو الأعلى منذ
أكثر من 50 عامًا
[موسيقى  ]
هناك شيء خاطئ في تفكيرهم
تحت حكم بايدن والديمقراطيين الراديكاليين
تم الاستهزاء بأمريكا وجعلها
على ركبتيها ربما لم يسبق لها مثيل
ولكننا هنا الليلة لنعلن
أنه لا يجب أن يكون الأمر بهذه الطريقة ولا
يجب أن يكون بهذه الطريقة
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك ،
لن تكون هذه حملتي ، بل
ستكون حملتنا معًا
[موسيقى]
لأن الأربعة فقط هم الأقوياء بما يكفي
لهزيمة الفساد الهائل
هل أنت ضد الشعب الأمريكي ، هذا
صحيح ، لكن كما وعدت في عام 2016 ، أنا
صوتك ، أنا صوتك
أجنبي
[موسيقى]